okay welcome back so we're talking about
the controllability of the system X dot
equals ax plus bu and remember though
the reason we want to know if the system
is controllable is because we want to we
want to know if it's possible to design
a control law u equals KX to make the
system have desired stability properties
or performance okay and we have this
simple test in terms of the rank of the
controllability matrix but there are a
number of other interesting tests for
the controllability of a system of
equations and I'm going to tell you
about one really really interesting one
called the Popov béla [ __ ] how to
houses the p bh test okay and the p bh
test so I just remember the Popov cheap
vodka the pop of the pbh test is an
extremely simple test for
controllability it rivals this in terms
of how simple it is but you also get a
tremendous amount of insight into why
and how a system is controllable okay so
the pbh test is extremely simple so the
pair a comma B is controllable is VTR B
if and only if right so if and only if
the following is true the rank of a
minus lambda times the identity matrix
so that's an N by n matrix and be our
input actuation matrix if this rank
equals n for all lambdas in the complex
plane very simple to say okay it's
simple to say this a and B matrix is
controllable which is equivalent to this
having rank M the a and B pairs is
controllable isn't only if the rank of
this N by n matrix
concatenated with the columns and B is n
for every single lambda in the complex
plane very simple and there's some
immediate outfalls
that I think are really useful so first
of all just think about this object is n
by n object when does this thing have
rank n okay so I always ask my students
this when does a minus lambda I have
rank N or maybe more specifically when
does this not have rank n so when this
thing is rank deficient that's the only
time that this determinant is equal to
zero and that is the eigenvalue equation
determinant of this matrix equal zero is
the eigenvalue equation it's only
satisfied for at most n special lambdas
that are eigenvalues so if lambda is not
an eigenvalue of a this matrix alone has
rank N and I don't even need be okay so
first fact that's super interesting is
that we only show the rank so rank of a
minus lambda I equals n except for eigen
values eigen values lambda so what that
means is that I only have to test this
pbh test at the eigen values of a so
it's this is for all lambda in the
complex plane but we only need to test
at eigen values that make sense because
this makes your has rank n unless lambda
is an eigen value that's if it lambda is
an eigen value that's the definition of
this being ranked efficient and so we
only need to take tests of pbh test at
most n eigen values lambda of a so we
went down from all of the complex plane
which was a really hard would be really
hard to test and now we just have to
test this writing condition at all of
our eigen values okay now let's think a
little deeper about this let's pick an
eigen value and plug it in here so we
know that a minus lambda I is now ranked
deficient
but in what direction is a minus lambda
I rank deficient well if I look at like
the null space of this that's the
eigenvector right this thing this thing
is is ranked deficient in exactly the
eigenvector direction the eigenvector is
what makes this multiply it to equal
zero so what that means is essentially
another fact we have is that the only
way that this matrix is ranked efficient
is in the eigenvector direction and so
for this to be controllable for this to
have rank n this actuation vector or
column or set of vectors B has to
complement it has to have some component
in that eigenvector direction that will
allow it to be linearly independent from
this matrix okay
so B needs to have some components in
each eigenvector direction okay and let
me just say that one more time because I
think this is super important and I want
to make sure it's crystal clear so we're
trying to make this matrix have rank and
for the system to be controllable we
only have to test it I in values of a
these specific lambdas and if we plug in
one of those eigen values this thing is
only rank deficient in the eigen vector
directions corresponding to that eigen
value so for this to be true for all of
those lambdas then B has to have some
component in that eigen vector direction
that's missing from this so this rank
would be like n minus 1 and I need that
B column vector to be in the eigenvector
direction or at least have some
component in all of the eigenvector
directions and so a really really
important outfall of this is that three
and this is kind of advanced okay so
this is super cool I'm just going to say
this is advanced so for those of you who
like compressed sensing and randomized
linear algebra this is going to be
really really neat and intuitive to you
so
if B is a random projection so if B is
so for B let me just write this out in
words if B is a random vector okay so in
other words if B equals R and n n by 1
it's literally a random column vector
then a B will be controllable with high
probability so this is kind of the
modern way of saying that with high
probability okay so what that means is
the following
so we know that to be controllable these
this actuation B can't okay so it can't
be aligned with one eigenvector only if
B is an eigenvector of a then this will
have rank n for that particular lambda
but for all other lambdas this won't
help okay this won't make that have rank
n so B has to have at least some
component in every eigen vector
direction and the really amazing thing
is that if I select B randomly if I just
pull out a random vector from RN with
high probability it's going to have a
little bit in all of those eigen vector
directions I'd have to get extremely
unlucky for B to be aligned with one or
two or you know only a few eigen vectors
and so it's highly likely very very
likely that a random vector a random B
vector is going to have some component
in all of the eigenvector directions of
a and so with high probability this will
have rank n for all eigen values lambda
that's really really remarkable is that
if this is even if this is like a very
high dimensional system a million by a
million dimensional system if I pull out
a random B vector in RN with high
probability it's going to be able to
control all of those states in RN that's
really really remarkable and
cool and it kind of relies on some of
this randomized linear algebra ideas
that if you just randomly sample a
vector it's going to have some component
in all basic directions okay it's going
to be unlucky for it to be aligned with
any one eigenvector of a okay and so
this is really remarkable another thing
that I think is super cool is this
actually tells you how many control
channels so remember we've been acting
like B is just a column vector which
means that there's only one control knob
you but in principle right X is a vector
a is a matrix B is a matrix you could be
a vector of control inputs okay so I
could have multiple input channels you
like I could have u1 and u2 and u3 and
so on and so forth the pbh test tells me
how many what is the minimal number of
actuators I can get away with what's the
minimal number of columns B I need for a
given a matrix and it has to do in
particular with the multiplicity of the
eigen values of a so the only way that
this subspace that this can be ranked
efficient in more than one direction is
that this thing has an eigenvalue with
multiplicity greater than one so if a if
the a matrix has a repeated eigen value
let's say it has an eigenvalue of one
and then another eigenvalue of one it
can actually have a two dimensional it
can it can have two directions in which
this matrix how do I want to say this
there can be two directions to
eigenvector directions that are in the
null space of this operator and so I
would need two columns of B to fill in
that null space and have a rank n
condition so let me say that again if I
have a simple eigenvalue one eigenvalue
that's not repeated all my eigenvalues
are distinct it doesn't matter if i have
a billion dimensional state vector and a
billion by billion a matrix i can get
away with having a single input column
you a single input column B and I can
control all of those billion directions
as long as I have distinct eigen values
because this thing will never have more
than
one direction in which it's ranked
efficient and I can I can essentially
compliment it with this B vector now if
I have an eigenvalue that has
multiplicity greater than one i have a
repeated eigenvalue with that it's
repeated three times that tells me I
need three independent columns of B to
fill in that rank so I need three inputs
I need three control knobs if I have a
multiplicity three eigen value this is
really remarkable we learn just from the
simple test I don't actually use this
test I use it to think about when
something is controllable and how
controllable and things like that so
don't actually ever compute this rank
but it tells you these very important
properties of random vectors are almost
certainly controllable or if I have
multiplicity two eigen value I need to
control input channels and where this
gets interesting is there are gray areas
so what if I have two eigen values that
are really really close they're not
exactly equal or what if I have two
eigen vectors that are SuperDuper close
but not exactly equal so these things
are approximately degenerate again I
might have a this binary condition might
say yes the system is controllable but
it might be barely controllable so
sometimes I'd want to have multiple
columns of B anyway to boost my control
Authority if I have nearly degenerate
eigen values nearly a you know nearly
identical eigen values and so this can
give you an idea those gray areas where
this thing is almost rank deficient in
two directions and so maybe I need to
control columns to boost my control
Authority okay I just have to show you
this because I mean there's many many
tests again usually I don't actually
compute this for all of the eigen values
but it gives you a very nice way of
thinking about when assistance
controllable in terms of the eigen
values and the eigen vectors of a it
tells you what kinds of B vectors I want
I want to be that can reach all of the
eigen vectors of a right that's a very
simple thing I want B to be able to kind
of align with all of the eigen vector
directions of a and if I have a subspace
corresponding to an eigen value with a
repeated eigen value
I need multiple columns of B to satisfy
this rank condition
so to simultaneously control those
multiplicity you know two or greater
directions I need multiple control
columns actuation columns okay thank you